like the saying goes april showers bring
may games and this may has a little
something for everyone from slashing and
shooting to racing and platforming
you're bound to love at least one of
these here's a list of the biggest games
releasing in may 2022
sniper elite 5 takes place in 1944 and
sees you following the story of carl
fairborne a u.s ranger that uncovers a
shocking project that could spell
disaster for the allies you'll trek
across real world locations that have
been painstakingly recreated to offer an
authentic experience before taking aim
at your enemies using the high-end
sniping mechanics the series has become
known for sniper elite 5 also features a
robust cooperative and pvp mode which
allows you to invade other players games
and put an end to their mission
reading that last part gave me death
loot flashbacks sniper elite 5 is taking
aim at pc and every current gen console
except for switch on may 26th
evil dead the game is an online co-op
shooter from saber interactive featuring
characters and locations from the
popular horror movie franchise these
characters include ash williams his
younger sister cheryl lord arthur and
more over 25 weapons can be found
throughout the game including ash's
trademark gauntlet boomstick and
chainsaw in our preview of the game phil
hornshaw said evil dead feels like two
games rolled together for humans it's a
third person action game that's all
about coordination planning and ripping
enemies apart meanwhile the demon player
is almost more of a dungeon master in
many cases finding good spots to drop
tougher enemies and traps to slow the
other team down and waiting for the
perfect moment to strike with the
possession evil dead the game is coming
to ps4 ps5 xbox one series x and s
switch and pc on may 13th
a follow-up to salt and sanctuary salt
and sacrifice is another souls inspired
metroidvania from ska studios that
tosses you into a land plagued by
twisted mages you play the role of a
marked inquisitor and it's up to you to
hunt down the mages and take them out on
your journey you'll craft unique weapons
and armor master runic arts and explore
a large labyrinth world either alone or
with a buddy in online co-op but beware
because friends aren't the only players
you'll encounter assault and sacrifice
also features pvp salt and sacrifice
will be available on may 10th for ps4
ps5 and pc
trek to yomi follows a young swordsman
named hiroki who has sworn to protect
his town as a vow to his dying master
the game is a 2d adventure game with a
black and white filter similar to ghosts
of sushima's kirasawa mode which was
named after the legendary filmmaker
akira kirisawa beyond that aesthetic you
can expect plenty of 2d hacking and
slashing as you make use of hiroki's
lethal skills to face against threats
beyond life and death trektiomi is being
developed by flying wild hog the studio
behind the rebooted shadow warrior games
so if you're into those there's a chance
you might dig this one too trek taomi
will release on ps4 5 xbox one siriusx
and s and pc on may 5th
dolmen is described as taking a sci-fi
approach to souls-like combat but after
watching a couple trailers i can also
see a little bit of eternal mixed in
there as well in dolman you're thrown
into the hostile alien planet of revion
prime your goal is to bring back samples
of special crystals that will
revolutionize space travel sounds simple
right well that might be true if the
monsters of the planet were friendly not
to worry though because you'll have tons
of weapons melee and ranged at your
disposal couple those weapons with your
character's energy mode that imbues them
with elemental effects and you're ready
to take on anything this dark and
twisted planet can throw at you dolman
is coming to pc and every current gen
console except for switch on may 20th
first released in october of 2019
deliver us the moon is a sci-fi thriller
set in an apocalyptic near future where
the natural resources of earth are
depleted weird how descriptions like
that are starting to feel more real in
the game you play as an astronaut that
is sent to the moon in order to save
everyone from extinction so if you miss
playing it the first time around or just
want to experience it again on better
hardware you can do that when deliver us
the moon rockets onto ps4 and xbox
series xns on may 19th
vampire the masquerade swan song is a
narrative rpg in which you play as three
vampires with storylines that intertwine
your goal is to find the right balance
between human and animal in a story
where choices can determine the fate of
the three characters and of boston each
character has their own upgradeable
abilities and you can choose how to
approach different situations using
intimidation seduction or stealth
prepare to make some heart pounding
decisions when vampire the masquerade
swan song releases on ps4 5 xbox one
series x and s switch and pc on may 19th
if you miss the good old days of playing
a bright cartoony animal platformer on
your ps2 or gamecube then the new cow
the kangaroo might be for you in the
game you play as cow on a quest to find
out what happened to your missing father
pretty deep for a cute cartoon game this
game isn't cow's first adventure though
but it still offers new challenges for
him to overcome as well as secrets to
uncover one of those secrets lie in the
mysterious and powerful gloves that cow
uses to explore and defeat foes kyle the
kangaroo is punching and hopping his way
onto every current gen console and pc on
may 27th
pac-man museum plus is the sequel to
2014's pac-man museum that features 14
games from the pac-man franchise these
titles range from the 1980 original to
the 2015
pac-man 256 a game that was not a part
of the first museum collection other new
additions include pack and time pac-man
arrangement pack motors and pack and
roll remix and possibly the coolest
feature for retro enthusiasts is the
customizable arcade mode in the game you
can walk around a virtual arcade as the
yellow ghost eater and design the room
to your liking using decorations that
you can purchase using in-game currency
and don't worry these coins are earned
by just playing games and completing
missions the pack is back on may 27th
for ps4 xbox one switch and pc
in this retro inspired 2d metroidvania
you're whisked away to a mythical land
on the fringes of the afterlife soldiers
is described as having souls like combat
very common these days and you'll be
slashing dodging and parrying your way
through dozens of tough enemies the
game's pixel art world is packed with
details and there are secret pathways
and treasures to find all over so
there's releases on may 19 for ps4 5
xbox one xbox series x and s switch and
pc and there's even a demo on steam
right now for those looking to try it
out
at least in april of 2020 snow runner is
an off-road simulation game that will
test your patience in this follow-up to
mud runner you're tasked with delivering
goods across unforgiving terrain in your
choice of 40 unique vehicles with
advanced physics you can take on the mud
water snow and frozen lakes alone or
with up to four friends in co-op snow
runner is driving onto ps5 and series
xns on may 31st so which of these games
are you most excited to play personally
i'm excited to try out dolman it could
be pretty fun remember to make sure
you're subscribed to gamespot so you can
catch the reviews for some of these
games when they release and we'll see
you soon for the biggest games of june
[Music]